sometimes people ask me how were you
called in the ministry the question
seems to always come as that person is
questioning their own vocation to
ministry or as a scientist or whatever
wondering how you know exactly what
you're supposed to do with your life I
wish I had a dramatic story like Saul on
the road to Damascus who was breathing
threats against the disciples of Jesus
and a light from heaven beamed into the
ground and the voice of Jesus called him
into ministry very clear no booming
voice of Jesus here calling down from
heaven and knocking me to the ground I
wish I could tell you that like the
legend about Martin Luther a bolt of
lightning struck right near where I was
walking and knocked me to the ground it
was the very moment that Luther promised
that he would become a monk no lightning
strike either no booming voice from
heaven no lightning strikes how do you
know people ask well sometimes you don't
or sometimes it's a process and almost
always it's a long journey probably has
been for you too or it currently is but
now that I think about it there was a
persistent light a beacon guiding me
toward paths as yet on trodden in the
words of my favorite prayer the light
was a mentor who nudged me to consider
seminary a word I had never heard the
light grew stronger when my family
supported this crazy idea the light was
strongest when I was invited in to share
as part of a church community to try on
the role and find that it might be a fit
even if it's far from perfect in
addition to this kind of light leading
me I also had a group of wise ones to
travel with and the desire to search for
the Christ I was only just beginning to
get to know this is epiphany a season of
the church year when we remember how
Christ has been revealed to the world an
invitation to look up and see if there
may be something
guiding us following beyond the edges of
the map searching for the Christ we may
just be getting to know we don't know
much about these Magi do we we read that
they followed a star to Bethlehem but
who were they they may have been Kings
they may have been astronomers there may
have been three but likely many many
more there may have been women in
addition to the wise men that get all
the press in Matthew what about that
star was it a comet a supernova
explosion a planet well as tempting as
it is I think we should stop trying to
explain the mystery right out of this
story I know if we could only just pin
down the astrological event of that
place in time we could explain how the
Magi were led by that star and it would
finally make sense if we could evoke a
scientific explanation Christ's birth
wouldn't need to be so mysterious but
the mystery is what makes it holy the
mystery means that god only knows and
God may have tossed a star in the sky to
guide strangers to a child stranger
things have happened in the Bible this
mysterious story means that God may also
be guiding us if we could just look up
from the GPS and accept that getting a
little lost is the way to be found this
is epiphany and instead of careful
intentions about this new year which we
probably already abandoned instead of
beating up on ourselves for failing in a
dozen ways today and it's only eleven
o'clock I think epiphany calls us to
practice a few things but all of them in
community trusting that there is
abundant grace when we mess up first
look up James is right for the first
time it doesn't look blue in here we can
see we can see where there were tarps we
can now see some light
I don't know about you but I spent a lot
of time looking down and it's not
because I'm extremely tall looking at my
phone looking at the sidewalk looking at
a book staring at my computer navel
gazing they call it when we focus only
on ourselves in worship too I spent a
lot of time looking at my bulletin
turning my eyes toward the ground in
reverent prayer it's important to look
up if the Magi had only looked down at
maps they would not have seen that
bright star above or notice that it was
indeed moving leading them and when they
finally arrived they looked up and saw
Jesus the promised king with their own
eyes what have you been overly focused
on lately is God calling you to look up
to notice something or someone you've
been missing give it a try just as I
want to yell it some distracted people
as they text and walk J walk across Elm
Street look out look up epiphany calls
to us look up the Magi looked up and saw
a star and believed it may just be
something to follow and this may be our
second task during epiphany to follow a
star even when we don't know exactly
where it is leading us maybe instead of
a star it's a hunch you have about how
God is calling you to serve in the world
maybe instead of a star it's an
invitation to try something new but
you're scared sometimes we need to
follow even when we don't know where the
star is leading whether it's in
relationships or career plans or any
aspect of our lives make plans but hold
them lightly when the Magi finally
arrived and met the Christ child they
worshiped him they didn't know much
about him and I'm sure they spent many
hours on that journey asking questions
about this child but they believed that
Jesus was the King born to save the
world and they worshiped him
they offer the most costly gifts they
had and they were overwhelmed with joy
if we can seek Christ with only a
fraction of their urgency and a portion
of their persistence we too can
experience this joy the call of epiphany
is to worship Christ even if you're just
getting to know who he is but then what
from here the story gets messy fast read
on in Matthew but here's what I think
the Magi encountered Christ and then
they took the light of Christ back home
with them and out into the world they
came face-to-face with God and God's
radiance must have just been shining
through them reflecting off of them in
the words of Isaiah which we just heard
and sang arise shine for your light has
come and the glory of the Lord has
dawned upon you not always convinced
this is good news we are supposed to
arise and shine I don't think Isaiah
knows how tired we are even after a
little break there is a deeper tiredness
that I hear and shining sounds like a
whole lot of pressure if God's glory has
dawned upon us are we supposed to act
think or be a certain way certainly more
perfect than we live now the important
thing to remember I think is that we
reflect God's light we are not the
source of the light if we glow with our
own happiness or joy this morning
unfortunately we know that this is not
always a permanent glow life has its ups
and downs if we are inspired and shining
forth brilliance that the world must
know soon enough we are proven wrong we
are not the source of all light and
truth which personally sounds like a
relief we are instead
called to reflect christ light to the
world seems to me that to reflect christ
light means to look up and be near
enough to Christ that we are catching
some of that light we can't give away
what we don't already have so the first
bask in the light of Christ seems
important come to worship then look for
God in the world seek Christ and the
freedom he brings and whatever joy
encouragement love or sustenance you've
received from Christ is a gift to you
but not a gift to store up for a rainy
gray winter's day it is a gift to
reflect to the world a friend of mine
has been waiting for our church to
ordain him for many years not only has
this long wait been financially very
costly the process has been costly to
his spirit as well but Chris wagamon is
reflecting Christ's radiant light in his
persistence in his faithfulness to the
call that God has given him to share
Christ light with the world recently he
wrote with such conviction that I just
have to share this with you he writes
preaching is a vocation to which I have
been called even if it looks as though
I'm not going a traditional route in
being called to serve a church going to
have to find or make my own way the word
is too important to just keep inside if
it is burning within you no matter how
imperfect your vessel the call of the
spirit transcends all human bonds and
what must be spoken must be spoken
this is epiphany looking up following
uncertain roads worshipping Christ and
reflecting Christ's light to the world
because the word is just too important
to keep to yourself it if it is burning
within you no matter how imperfect your
vessel you need to let it shine arise
shine for your light has come and the
glory of God has dawned upon you so let
it shine let it shine let it shine amen